I think perks is moving from the midlane
into the ad carry role or Marchman I
guess you call it nowadays I see you got
your Ottoman available I don't need to
die all right but will upset me the
nicest throw down flaps use defensively
perch the chases him down it was a
pixel-perfect fight seeker basically I
had some like kind of pain neurons in
this area and like like an the bottom of
my thumb I guess the bomb you know maybe
see the car filled snack just a maxout
but for now we're gonna turn our
attention to the bot lane the play is
starting kick off with deed now I'm
actually gonna get run down your purse
with no mana but what's one more auto is
going to go over to Mickey indeed
and botlane from g2 once again
dominating roll clumps don't happen very
often in competitive League of Legends
so in Perks one of the best mid laners
in europe decided to play ad carry
people weren't sure about how it worked
out
but he did it in part because one
support player was worth it
Mickey X was so good that perch was
willing to throw his legacy aside and
risk it all on a roll swap the pair was
underestimated over and over again but
despite a wrist injury
despite the doubters despite the history
of roll swaps their success created one
of the best following duos in the world
[Music]
after placing top four at world's 2018
g2 made a series of roster changes that
shocked the community and proved that
they weren't going to settle for good
enough we have decided to make an
incredibly radical lineup change as you
guys know we are peaking caps former
front and fnatic mid laner as a mid
laner for us
Perks is moving from the mid lane into
the ad carry role or Marchman I guess
you call it nowadays g2 dropped their
bot Lane before signing caps fnatic
superstar mid laner and rival to perks
as well as a Mickey X misfits star
support but long before the signing was
even confirmed when rumors were still
spreading everybody was asking the same
question what the [ __ ] was g2 doing so I
didn't believe the rumors were true I
genuinely couldn't get my head around
perks moving to bot lane and cat moon to
me I'm fascinated to see how it will
work out because on paper this is one of
the strongest mechanical teams that I
think Europe has ever produced
however wool that many stars be able to
coordinate and cooperate I don't know g2
star mid laner gave up his position to
his biggest rival not just because you
wanted to play ad carry but because he
wanted to play ad carry with me I had my
eyes on Miki for for awhile I was
basically like watching me enhance Tokyo
and they were like they were really
really good and they were like so high
rank they were like almost like one Kop
or something in challengers so I thought
this guy is really really [ __ ] good
I want to play with him when I tilt he
tells me no no it's okay or let's play
one more or it is fine and same when I
do something very good in game
Mickey like makes sure that I know that
is something would say that complements
me like makes me feel special you know
my role swapping perks that put himself
in a difficult position in the history
of competitive league of Legends you
players had ever done it and found real
success well it was a bit it was a bit
shaky a bit rocky because I'm playing a
new role and I'm not really familiar
with like all the matchups and
everything and I'm not really like super
confident yet I'm quite confident that I
will become the best by putting together
a roster with so much of year of the
best talent g2 had gone all in the
creation of this new g2 roster picking
up so much fantastic sound
I think Mickey is a really
underappreciated pick up the fact that
he is such a talented support gonna be
paired up with a mechanical powerhouse
that his books I'm excited to see how
this duel will work out
perks that a shot of rising to the
occasion and dominating in his second
role joining the ranks of players like
score and ambition I chose to do it
because I thought that I could be I
could be the best and likely what I do
like playing both right and it was the
best chance of me to get a good roster
so yeah I think that's the best possible
roster I could get and that's what I did
but there was also a chance he crashed
and burned and while the community was
excited to see person's potential some
analysts were cautious about how this
would all pan out I mean what is g2
gonna do I mean honestly it's a trick
question and I'm gonna be honest with
you I think there's a better likelihood
the team crashes and burns and fails and
succeeds now can it work yes of course
at the whole point of super teams but
I'm not gonna buy into the hype I need
to see what perks is gonna do his name
to carry an agency of perks can bring
his leadership and his mentorship from
this role which traditionally has not
been a role that has allowed captains or
leaders or callers to succeed once they
proved to me it'll work then I will
believe that you two can finally be good
on the international scene
but until then it's a superteam curse
that I'm more afraid of but as for perks
he wasn't about to let other people's
failures dictate his decisions
a lot people were saying that I can't do
it what he was saying that I'm just too
arrogant a lot of people were blaming me
for being being worse than cats and then
though going to bottom for ready no I it
was a lot of funny things I was reading
you know when we were talking about Luka
playing Eddie
I had a few doubts but after playing
with him and like just soloqueue and
talking to him he was really confident
and after playing with him as well in
soloqueue
I got a lot of confidence as well and I
thought to be really insane and so far
his dunk now on the back end but he
manages to pick up his 200 kill in
playoffs he goes in with your pistol
boys magic is already shut down very
very low whirling death will fly out and
come back and way too late now you've
died jumping in the back pop blossom
from Plex ap Neko does so much damage
you take other able to kill Mickey the
cold goes down caps would have it out
puts up another but gee
destroy LG g2 dominated even the strong
origin in 74 minutes and 32 seconds the
fastest time for playoff series in
European league history and captured
their fifth championship in the process
ladies and gentlemen the twitch chat
press f to pay respects because our
cheese funeral is coming up this is the
most dominant team Europe has ever
produced no team has ever won again
quicker than this
there was just one small issue basically
I had some like kind of pain around this
area and like like at the bottom of my
thumb I guess how to call the bomb you
know so for like the past month or so
last three weeks I think haven't played
a single soil game and I've played I
think eight games in total even though
Mickey was the starting support for most
of the spring split behind the scenes GT
were playing drama skew their support
substitute in many of their screens also
like to thank consoles or promise you
and I think he's really underrated and I
think it's really like undeserved flak I
guess by the community and I really just
like thank him for subbing in for me
like whenever I couldn't really play
these days eSports has the
infrastructure to support players
dealing with injuries even a few years
ago Mickey probably would have had to
play through the pain suffering
irreparable damage and potentially
ending his career prematurely I mean I
go to like a visitor Brazil ready for
like three weeks or four weeks and I've
been to the doctor as well and yeah
basically I just have to go through a
bunch of video sessions and not play
much and hope it gets better so yeah
it's been kind of boring but hopefully
now I'm gonna have like three week rest
and probably gonna try to not claim much
prob'ly not at all and there hopefully
it's good it gets better for players it
might seem like Mickey in parks are
playing together a lot during this
period but at the highest level
professional
the Pauling duo needs so much more
practice together than what they get on
stage so they were lagging behind the
rest of the competition we've been
playing more with Mickey now than before
but he still doesn't play so cute
sobbing I'm gonna get to practice me him
but I think we played pretty good
together anyways so I'm just happy to
play with him even though you get so few
games and stage Orion screams together
no I can cherish those moments more the
other fascinating thing about perks and
Mickey is the way that perks decided to
play ad carry or rather the way he
decided not to they catch McKean perks
off-guard and they find themselves first
blood Pat Metheny caught out by that
roots that you just talked about unless
she's careless from baby traditionally
ad carries claimed marksman rain scary
is that scale throughout the game and
while perks has played his fair share of
lucian mid he brought a slightly
different champion pool to the vault
lane pork's yas awoke in the bottom line
he's been playing ad carry's some of us
may have forgotten about his tendencies
in his history as a mid laner but you
also a balling of course a true terror
and even stronger now on this patch
perks
now roaming up could run into max or
this would be terrible reminder good
that's why he got to sleep but this will
happen to you and so love you too
you can play every champ in the game so
you can like flex a lot of pics and just
whenever time becomes meta he's like oh
I can play this though ADC even playing
non marksman lanes for over a year
hurts immediately stood out as one of
the most creative players in the role he
took his aggressive mid lane play style
and transferred it to the bot lane
not only did this forces opponents to
react to him it's also forced to Mickey
the change of his game he plays really
well already I like all the traditional
traditional Hades and he was really
aggressive so we liked it playing with
Mickey has been great because he like
kind of fuels me to play aggressive and
the only thing is that we have to
control ourselves and that's what we're
learning to do because
new Boston and I'm a new boat dinner in
general so yeah I am trying to be more
disciplined but thorough diving is
definitely one of our specialties and
now I'm looking for the Kaku there's a
teleport coming in as well with the help
of cats but was a few weeks to go until
MSI Mickey posted an emotional message
to Instagram saying that due to the
nature of his injury promised he would
be traveling with the team to Vietnam
and Mickey's chances of playing in the
tournament were iffy at best so far I've
played like two games a day of screams
so I think I'll keep doing that but yeah
it kinda sucks if we're going to go to
Korea boot camp and like I won't be able
to really play the solo queue or scream
against the goo teams so it's kind of
bittersweet I guess but two weeks for
the tournament g2 is a medical team gave
Mickey the green light to compete at MSI
after months of pain uncertainty and his
own body holding him back Mickey was let
loose hey guys I just decided that I'll
be playing tomorrow and stage or
anything
I gotta leave my hands I'm feeling a lot
better and yeah I'm really wanna playing
is missed with the energy and then I'll
see after that but I think I could
probably
gentlemen about getting pretty good so
yeah I'm gonna hopefully see you
tomorrow on the stage in those two weeks
Mickey and perks practiced around the
clock and by the time msi rolled around
g2 is unconventional bot lane duo we're
ready to show the world just what they
were capable even if it's me playing a
new role it's us not playing with our
main support for a long time like even
though all these are obstacles that we
like I have to hit overcome to even be
in Europe I'm still confident in us
winning the whole thing and that's just
the feeling that you don't really get to
have often so I don't know if it's
asking to your IG I just won't do it
you're asked to say I'm pleasantly
surprised by just how well Mickey X &
purtz
are playing they've gotten two or three
duo kills in Lane just across this
tournament they have been actually
dominant as a dual I would say overall
and we knew they were good but to
actually step up so well has been
impressive looking for the black shield
if it's available gonna throw down a
little bit late exhausted by some time
it's soul shot goes into stop 1 Worley
jet comes out
first kill a VC for a VC as a - and
apartment of dazzle this means up cash
gets on the board if now rod has taken
down and harder fear us for his life
Teddy has already recalled and
teleported back to Lane he's sitting on
that Sheen for fields Warhammer for
perks as he gets caught out take a look
at the mini-map that fake is coming from
mid lane look Kurt gets first blood
automata teddy is turn a step for the
12th is going to come out capture trying
to find the kill that much as a total
fakers work but they've already got one
it's a lotta where is Teddy follow his
HP bar that contacts the board a nice
tip yeah goes into the pit
g2 eSports have been gifted and donated
any parent from SKT Karen and the base
where were you
to conquer champions g2 eSports
eliminates SK Telecom North America face
Europe with the other side finals the
semi-final saw Mickey and perks defeat
escapees fearsome bot lane duo of Teddy
and Mata toppling the Korean powerhouse
three to two which set up a historic EU
versus na Grand Finals against Team
Liquid I mean this is history and then a
versus EU finals is something people
dreamed about since the early days of
League repositioning that from poor
JDate to keep his ad carry alive they're
gonna go going on xmithie they know
doubled isn't there though slow is there
on a tomcat you can eat it for a little
bit but he's gonna be knocked up and
here comes a TV from everyone else
they've got to buy some time before
today gonna die yet again no TV for
doubled instead it's Swain here and the
gameplay goes well the barrels clever
there's no shame he's gonna flash back
to safety the knockout pill again
they're gonna get ya
and she to leave the game with three
kills at six minutes here's the engaged
I wonder once again if they look for
these kills a big charter knocking on
the back line it's already one kill make
it a second as these team living members
are falling fast and furious g2 esports
in commanding fashion will take Game one
the 2019 MSI finals Europe versus North
America and g2 strikes first Mickey and
perks destroyed SS and poor JJ TL very
own revered botlane duo and slept na
strongest team 300 in 70 minutes and 43
seconds making it the fastest
best-of-five in international league
history and g2 ripped through the hearts
of team that could a North American fast
as they secured themselves in the top of
the world there is no chance TL comes
back from this they're already on axis
turret this is what peak league of
legends looks like and it comes from
Europe a world record gee Joe eSports
zero will win a Masonic 2019
[Applause]
[Music]
Mickey and perks are the perfect
encapsulation of gee whose presence in
league of legends bold
mechanically talented and open to new
creative ideas they're a duo that
approaches the game in a different way
how me a Mickey started I suppose by
duel queuing and diving anything what
level to every single game and then if
it works it works if it doesn't work
sucks we try again they subscribe to the
idea that no strategy or champion is off
limits as long as you can show that it
works yeah whenever we Lin drops is just
really fun like we pick one gem and they
say we discuss where it's gonna go and
go BOTS top jungle mid support because
we all play a lot of chimps it's this
idea of the creativity that they don't
play standard League of Legends that
they will change up the temple became
the course of the game and they will
force you to play reactive they will
force you to play on their tiles this
thinking requires an inherent trust in
the other players of judgment something
that extends to all of g2 so I mean
we've been anything a lot of ad carry's
but we were going into Game five and
purpose said if I get an image then it's
three win so we can't affect somebody
that trusts that creativity it's a big
part of how g21 MSI even them did not
practice like we were actually winning
our lanes be able to trust in each other
and there's a bit too much so we've been
together really hard or we lose together
really hard it's how they've been able
to stay on top of this summer in Europe
to g2 win because they aren't afraid to
short convention here's the thing they
can play whatever the [ __ ] they weren't
is unbelievable so
and then you have a really creative
coaching stuff that also allows them
with their madness they pick heroes
because they like the skin not because
it makes sense in their setup it doesn't
make any sense looking ahead to worlds
though assuming G to make it things
could be a little different the world
has seen Jeter's playstyle now and other
teams will probably be more ready for
them but whatever happens at Worlds you
can't take that MSI trophy away from g2
even in the face of injury adversity and
limited practice time perks and Mickey
went into a tournament packed with the
best talent in the world and played
their game I mean this guy has gone
through so much this year working
through injuries coming out onto the
internet international stage and
performing so well there's got to be a
good feeling there's always some part of
you that wants like whoever I'm wrong
for whether I'm right though well and
however like believe me and I'm mostly
doing it for myself as well I want to
enjoy what I'm doing and not be clouded
by just spinning the games when it was
all over perks lifted his first
international trophy after playing his
second professional role for just one
split it's quite something that me went
in your room would actually result in me
winning my first international title
after only three months of playing with
this team it seems just quite surreal
and his lane partner stood beside
lifting history with his own hand
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you will find anywhere
else hit up our Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages